bon jour given us under president
welcome to the Commission's press room
for our weekly press readouts we have
the president of the Commission
jean-claude Juncker and the president of
the European Investment Bank mr. van
Horn with us today I give the floor to
the president young man is efendim
ladies and gentlemen pleased to see you
in in good form this kind of pre-holiday
feeling I'd like to welcome the
president of the European Investment
Bank
mr. then ahoy and the driving force
between the investment plan now I've
been in China and Japan back now to
chair the Commission meeting and I'm
very pleased to be able to have mr.
Hoyer here and I think it's good if we
can report before the summer break on
what we've done in the investment plan
field in recent years thanks to the
European Investment Fund for strategic
investment paper the European front for
strategic investment has seen 335
million euros in additional investment
coming in what many had their doubts
about from the outset we have seen the
leverage effect from this investment
plan this has allowed us to reach
virtually the same investment level as
we had before the financial crisis
the plan itself does impact on many
different areas many different projects
which range from project that has
already managed to place hundreds of
refugees and migrants of Finnish labour
market
cancer research for children and a wind
farm in Greece has been set up that's
one where 30% has come in already 20% in
the for energy then for research and for
digital and transport the rest of the
investment for social and the
environmental affairs 15 million
additional households have been given a
broadband connection that has been made
possible by the plan and 500,000 new or
renovated and above all affordable homes
have been created 700,000 SMEs in Europe
have been able to benefit from the plan
750,000 new jobs have been created and
EU GDP has risen naught point 5 percent
this has been made possible because we
have made sure that the European
Investment Bank and the European
Commission have worked seamlessly on
this together a lot of this is down to
Verna hoya himself it wouldn't have been
possible without him
we have if I remember it was November
2014 we started on this Verner and
myself met in July before the European
Parliament vote we sat down and started
thinking about this plan back then and
I'm very grateful to him that he has
taken the lead on this on this plan and
I'd like to thank others who have been
involved with this plan this works you
can't do anything on your own you need
others you can't do this on your own
I can't move where we were China or
Japan said that Caesar conquered Egypt
but he also said his cooks with him and
there are the cooks the chefs in the
front row here and I'd like to thank
them very much indeed as well this plan
will continue in the coming years by
2020 we're looking at to raising this to
500 billion but we all have the EU
invested plan coming into into force and
hopefully something that has started so
well and it's a promising we'll be able
to continue in 2020 the 1.4 billion jobs
will have been created and the EU GDP
will rise by 1.3 percent which is not a
negligible contribution you have to say
the investor EU plan and the Yonker plan
together and the new financial
instruments will be used in the future
the Parliament has asked for 200 million
euros to be used and there were some
discussions about and debts and
contracting new debts but the private
sector has actually stepped in and the
lion's share of the investment has come
from the private sector under the EU
investment plan six hundred and fifty
billion will come from private
investment I'd like to thank president
Toya for being such an inspiration
behind the original plan and for having
guided this project so smoothly along
its way the Commission is not a bank the
bank is not the Commission of course but
we have worked together on this in the
past and in the future this will come